[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment accusé qui nous a
beaucoup amusé les assurances de stars
on le savait mais à ce point là
donc quand on parle argent plusieurs
stars surtout américaines peuvent
assurer différentes parties de leur
corps afin de protéger leur gagne pain
les contrats engageant peuvent engager
par don peuvent atteindre des montants
énormes exemple quelques exemples vous
allez voir qu'ils s'affichent 8 millions
d'euros pour la voix de bruce
springsteen 149 millions d'euros pour le
corps de david beckham 20 millions pour
les fesses de kim kardashian 21 millions
d'euros pour les dents de julia roberts
est hallucinant 695 millions pour les
gens de mer la caresser pas sûr c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui faudra qu'on
m'explique un million d'euros pour le
sperme de david vie rose mais c'est
hallucinant on peut tout tout tout peut
on peut tout assuré aujourd'hui 41
millions d'euros pour la partie gauche
du cerveau de magali baird à ses fins il
comprendre déjà assuré qu est ce que ça
veut dire sébastien que ça veut dire
assurer une partie de son corps baïla
sur leurs jambes par exemple si il ya un
problème un jour qui se casse la jambe
et que c'est en plein milieu d'un
tournage des centaines de millions
devant de re l'assurance l'assurance
doit venir au secours de la produit
voilà et xavier hardy qui chante il perd
sa voix il peut pas sur un concert c'est
l'assurance qui va même si en dehors en
dehors d'un tournage il se casse la
jambe et qui avait un tournage prévu
plus tard etc
les assurances s'en occupe et justement
c'est ça m'était arrivé avec julia
roberts
aux états unis où j'étais en train de
faire des photos m courait après sa
première réaction en fait elle a été
arrête de me faire courir parce que si
je me casse une jambe
ça va te coûter cher donc voilà en fait
ils pensent vous n'avez pas compris à
l'époque ce que ça voulait dire et en
fait non je me reste pourquoi on parle
de ça
ouais mais bon tout est si elle est
mortellement s'était cassé une jambe en
courant après éventuellement se
retourner contre moi
s'il y avait un tournage de film à ce
moment là voilà ça aurait pu me coûter
pas ça voudrait bien plus alertes et
millions d'euros mon père un voile à
faire des photos quand même
voilà il faut partir mais on vous a posé
la question d'ailleurs sur twitter un
les stars qui assure une partie de leur
corps je comprends c'est leur outil de
travail où je ne comprends pas lucas
voilà vous avez été assureurs ma gueule
perdre à moi je fais sur herbe ont oui
mais non mais c'est vrai quoi le premier
métier j'ai été assuré à 21 ans mais
vous assuriez quoi je faisais
l'assurance de personne mais non
assurance de personnes ces compléments
fins et les mutuelles cesser les
garanties c'est le maintien de salaire
en cas d'arrêt de travail
il ya des pratiques et des français
people qui ont assuré une partie aux
siens sur quoi ou les sportifs sont
assurés c'est obligatoire il ya certains
chanteurs aussi qu'ils sont assurés mais
en france on a ce qu'on appelle le
maintien de salaire en cas d'arrêt de
travail tous les salariés quasiment ont
ce contrat on va dire que si demain ils
tombent malades qui se casse une jambe
qui peuvent plus travailler en
assurances prennent le relais pour
qu'ils gardent leurs salaires mais par
exemple séparatistes à moi qui suis
leader tnt
à cette heure-là et cette émission
importe de le dire on va se prendre une
taule demain si je devais parents pas
assurés soit mon visage pour absolument
vous avez raison vous avez tout à fait
raison
si votre visage c'est aussi un
instrument de travail pour vous
peut-être d'hommes d'image à tv6 demain
j'espère pas pourvoir vous étiez
défiguré vous auriez le droit de
dépenser et vous faire assurer par le
mont gabriel en europe ça pour vous
alors à la perte financière pour vous
pour la chaîne annonce réelle entre 500
et 1000 euros 1000 euros chaque semaine
depuis l'humiliation comme itunes miyako
oui je vais faire un peu d'histoire ce
que j'ai fouillé dans mes archives moi
j'ai cherché lui les magazines people
depuis 1908 à peu près de ma naissance
et alors non mais est ce que vous
connaissez bendter pin je passe comment
ça c'est bon c'était le partenaire de
charlot et il avait fait assuré devinez
quoi son strabisme
parce qu'en fait c'est son grand truc
c'était de l'ouche et c'est ce qui
faisait rire
donc il avait à fait assuré ça pour
25000 dollars donc on est dans l'est le
début du 19e siècle aussi nous laisser
du 20e siècle
finie la fed est sûre et son strabisme
ils tous vous qui avez connu toutes les
stars du monde entier américain et tout
ça vous avez une anecdote sur les
assurances de people que vous avez
connus ou pas du tout
absolument pas très bien merci beaucoup
enfin il se tait merci beaucoup